I'm here at Nerdcon Nerdfigheria,
about to get punished,
and these people are all voting on the things that I am going to blend.
Hello, people!
(Cheers)
Is this a situation that mustard is gonna improve?
Is it pudding?
Baked beans, ohh.
[John:] Do you have somebody filming for you?
[Hank:] No, I need someone to film for me.
Please film me.
First, we have...
Pop Tarts!
[John:] They are strawberry flavored.
[Hank:] Regular.
Is what flavor they are.
Hot dogs!
Now I think we were all rooting for a vegan blend there,
but it's not gonna happen this time.
Sriracha!
Smells spicy.
Have you never had sriracha?
'Cause you're gonna want it to have some heat.
Number four is baked beans!
[Maureen:] I'll be back.
[Hank:] It's got a little bit of beef in there.
Everyone stopped being excited just now.
Pudding!
Hank, I'm giving away the rest of your sriracha to this nice person in a sailor hat.
Peanut butter is happening now.
I don't know how to get the peanut butter in there
I got it, I got it.
And our final item on the list...
Mustard made it.
(crowd: peanut butter face!)
That's spoken like people who've never done peanut butter face, frankly.
[Hank:] All right,
[John:] Oh. Oh!
[Hank:] Come on, get down there.
[John:] Oh, it gets worse every time!
[Audience member:] You need to add some water.
[Hank:] Oh, no, yes, there needs to be something added,
but it's going to be almond milk.
[Hank:] ‘Cause it’s all I had.
[John:] That’s enough, that’s enough.
Just to be clear, you have to eat all of what is in there.
That's not happening.
Hopefully this will work.
I just saw the Pop Tart go down in a blaze of glory.
I am deeply regretting some decisions I've made in my past.
It looks like meat slurry.
It looks really, really bad.
[Maureen:] Is that the blender, that I just heard?
Yeah, that was the blender.
[Hank:] So you just stay back there, Maureen.
[Maureen:] I'm staying back here.
You're in the right place. Hank, can I smell it before you eat it?
Oh, no!
That was very bad.
I- I wish there was a way that we had smell-evision in here,
and we could just pump the whole auditorium full of what I just smelled.
[Maureen:] You guys, this was not in my contract.
Can I get one more sniff before you take a huge gulp?
I mean, that is very, very bad.
Chug, Chug, Chug, Chug, oh, oh!
I have a little more left.
When a Vlogbrother messes up, a Vlogbrother must be punished- it's very spicy!
It took a while for that to hit,
'cause the peanut butter was masking it.
Maureen, it's over.
Okay, Maureen. I put it away, Rodney has taken it away.
Except for this cup part, which you-
I'm not even being funny, legitimately queasy.
[Hank:] So I guess this is- Can I just?
[John:] Just chug.
Do what you need to do, Hank.
[Voice-over:] John, I survived. And it was, I think, worth it.
I loved last weekend so much. Thank you to everybody who came out.
And thank you also to you, John.
I'll see you on Tuesday.